you've mentioned kind of advice for
startups is there
in general whether you do a startup or
not do you have a device for young
people today
you're like an example of somebody who's
paid their own path
and where i would say exceptionally
successful is there advice
somebody who's like 20 today 18
undergrad
or thinking about going to college or in
college and so on
um that you would give them i think uh
i often tell young people don't start
companies
is it no don't start a company unless
you're prepared to make it your life's
work
like that's a really good way of of
putting it
and a lot of people think well you know
this semester i'm going to take a
semester off and in that one semester
i'm going to start a company and sell it
or whatever
right and it's just like what are you
talking about it doesn't really work
that way
you should be like super into the idea
so into it that you want to spend
a really long time on it um is that more
about psychology or actual time
allocation like is it literally
the fact that you need to give a hundred
percent for potentially years
for it to succeed or is it more about
just the mindset that
that's required yeah i mean i think well
any i think yeah you don't want to have
certainly don't want to have a plan to
sell the company
um like quickly or something what's like
or it's like a company that has a very
it's like a big fashion component
like it'll only work now it's like an
app or something
um so yeah i that's
that's a big one and then i also think
something i thought about recently is i
had a job as a quant
at a fund for about two and a half years
and part of me thinks if i had spent
another two years there
i would have learned a lot more
and had even more knowledge to to be
where to basically accelerate how long
numerix took
so the idea that you can sit in an
air-conditioned room
and get free food or even sit at home
now in your underwear
and make a huge amount of money and
learn whatever you want
and get it's just crazy it's such a good
deal
yeah oh that's interesting that's the
case for i was terrified of that like at
google i thought i would become
really comfortable in that
air-conditioned room
and that i was afraid the quant
situation is
is i mean what you present is is really
brilliant that
it's exceptionally valuable the lessons
you learn because you get to you get to
get paid while you learn from others if
you see that
if you see jobs in in the space of your
passion
that way that it's just an education
it's like the best kind of education
but of course you have from my
perspective to be really careful
not to get comfortable again in a
relationship then you buy a house or
whatever the hell it is and
then you get you know and then you
convince yourself like well i have to
pay these fees for the car for the
house blah blah blah and then and
there's momentum and all of a sudden
you're on your death bed and there's
grandchildren
and uh you're drinking whisking
complaining about kids these days
yeah so i you know that i'm afraid of
that momentum but you're right
like there's something special about the
education you get
working at these companies yeah and i i
remember on my desk i had the
like a bunch of papers on quant finance
a bunch of papers on optimization
and then the paper on ethereum just on
my desk as well and
the white paper and it's like it's
amazing how much
how kind of and you can learn about so
that i also
i think this like idea of like learning
about intersections of things
i don't think there are too many people
that know like as much about crypto and
quant finance
and machine learning as i do and that's
um a really nice set of three things to
know stuff about
and that was because i had like free
time in my job
you